-It is time for
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
Since the NBA and NHL playoffs
are happening,
I sent out the hashtag,
#AddAWordRuinASportsTeam.
And I asked you guys to take
the name of a sports team,
add one word
to change the meaning.
Within minutes
it was a trending topic,
so thank you so much
for playing along.
We love it.
We do it every week.
Now I'd like to share
some of my favorite
#AddAWordRuinASportsTeam
responses from you guys.
This first one is
from @centrewingdman.
He says,
"The San Jose Loan Sharks."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @susanavela.
She says,
"The Denver Chicken Nuggets."
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
-Nice. Nice.
-They have to sell that.
-One would hope.
This one's from
@limajuliettango.
She says, "The San Francisco
49-Year-Olds."
[ Laughter ]
That's funny.
-Oh, come on.
-This one is from
@andwejigglelike.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
Whoa!
-She says, "The Chicago
Build-A-Bears."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from
@unclethunderokc.
He says, "The Utah Jazz Hands."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, nice. That's nice.
♪♪
-This one is
from @coreyecone -- ecohen.
I thought it was Corey E. Corey.
-That'd be a good one.
You should do that
for your hashtag.
-I think that is a cool name.
Corey E. Corey
sounds like a cool --
like a new artist that I'm into.
-Yeah.
Who are you listening to now?
-I'm listening to
Corey E. Corey.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard he's fantastic, man.
-He's like Latin.
-Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
I know Corey E. Corey.
-Latin. It's Corey y Corey.
So it's two. They're twins.
-It's Corey and Corey.
There's two Coreys.
-They look like twins.
They're not actually.
-But they're not at all.
One's 49, the other is 12.
-Yes, correct.
[ Laughter ]
It's a 49-year-old Corey
and a 12-year-old Corey.
-Sad story.
His mother adopted him,
found him in the woods.
[ Laughter ]
-That's too much information.
Don't need to know that.
I like just hearing the music
and dancing.
-The music is fantastic.
-When you see the video,
it kind of bums you out.
-It's sad.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You go, "I don't know
if a 49-year-old
should be hanging out with
that 12-year-old."
It's weird."
But it's his legal guardian.
[ Laughter ]
-He adopted him
'cause his mother died.
You don't want to hear about it.
-Yeah, it's a terrible sad story
again.
-The video is black and white.
Sad.
The music is so peppy,
you'd think like --
-Yeah, it's peppy, a pop song --
-Yeah, pop.
-The video is set in a cemetery.
[ Laughter ]
Just awful.
-Creepy.
-And then he is crying.
They show baby photos,
and the baby is old Corey.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then the Sarah McLaughlin
song
at the end of their video
with the dog.
-No, no, people returning
adopted dogs back to the --
back to the place where
they adopted them from.
-It's awful!
-Terrible video.
One of the saddest things
I've ever seen in my lifetime.
-Sad. Cried. I wept.
I didn't even cry. I wept.
-And it's 15 minutes long.
-Yeah, who's gonna watch
a 15-minute-long video?
-Us.
-I guess me.
-Suckers.
-Suckers. Yeah, I gave it
a thumbs-up on YouTube too.
-I watched it like 16 times.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we had a bet.
-Yeah.
-How many times could you watch
the Corey y Corey
without crying.
-I cried every single time.
But the weird thing, the crying
started earlier each time.
-That was a fun weekend.
-That was a good weekend.
-You know, you wake up.
-Adirondacks.
-Wake and bake, dude.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-Fishing all day.
-Oh, vaping all day, dude.
-Oh, my God.
-People don't know that, off
camera, you just vape all day.
-I vape all day.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody looks uncool vaping.
That's my theory, yeah.
-Yeah, that's what you said.
And you have, like,
an R2-D2 vape.
-I have an R2-D2 vape --
-Dude, I think it's cool
'cause you wear, like,
board shorts and stuff.
-I wear board shorts.
I wear like O.C. stuff.
-Yeah, puka shell necklace.
-Puka shell.
I highlight my hair with lemon
so it gets a little --
-Yes, you have --
-Oakleys.
-Oakleys, but you don't wear
them. You just put them on --
-No, I put them around my neck
in the back.
-Yes, and they dangle.
-So I can pull them off
and go, "Yeah!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's just fun stuff.
-It's just cool, man.
-It's cool to listen to Corey E.
Corey and stuff like that.
-24/6.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, this is
from @coreyecohen.
[ Laughter ]
Where were we?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are we doing?
This is from @coreyecohen.
He says --
-Oh, this is from
Corey E. Cohen.
Oh, I understand
the misunderstanding.
-"The Carolina Sex Panthers."
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
-Rawr. Yeah, the Sex Panthers.
-[ Growls ]
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from
@nikolaydievski.
He says, "Comic Sans Antonio
Spurs."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-That's genius.
Can we see what that would look
like with that logo?
There you go.
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @realtwillah.
He says "The Milwaukee
Kombucha Brewers."
Eww, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @orenrmartin.
He says, "The Houston
Snot Rockets."
[ Laughter ]
That's funny.
This one's from
@joseramonmarmtz.
He says, "The Golden State
Ninja Warriors."
There you go.
They there are.
He's grabbing onto the rim.
He's flipping around.
There's no way
he's gonna make it.
He's not gonna ring that bell.
He did! He rang the bell!
[ Laughter ]
-And now, brought to you
by Corey E. Corey.
[ Laughter ]
-What was that?
-Awful! Awful!
-If you close your eyes,
it makes you happy.
That's the fun thing.
The song is poppy.
-The song is so poppy.
-And so fun.
-It's like pure bubble gum.
-It's like a beach ball.
It's like someone is hitting a
beach ball around in your head.
-And if you're in a bad mood,
you can just listen to
the music.
Not once you've seen the video.
-Once you've seen the video,
it's all ruined
and it goes downhill.
-Now it sounds like a calliope
of slow-motion, backward --
-You know what?
It's almost like torturing
myself because
I got to go back.
You know what? It makes me feel.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So you finally feel something.
Your dead heart
beats a little bit. Yeah.
-Yeah. It makes me
feel something.
When you listen to Corey.
-I don't care what it is.
It's a feel.
-Yeah, sure,
does the video make sense? No.
-No.
Is it super sad? Yes.
-Then I just found out
on the Internet --
-What?
Did you just check the Internet?
What happened?
-Corey sings Corey's parts.
-Oh! Are you serious?
So it's like Milli Vanilli?
-No, it's worse than
Milli Vanilli.
-Aw!
-I love Milli Vanilli, but --
One person felt sorry for them.
[ Laughter ]
No, what happens is Corey,
the older Corey...
-Older Corey.
-...is singing both parts.
He speeds up his voice.
The younger Corey doesn't sing.
[ Laughter ]
Just contract-wise, he refuses
to sing with his dad.
-Yeah, he can sing,
but there's -- Well, his "dad."
-He's a great singer.
-His "dad," yeah.
-I've seen him on "America's
Dancing with Talent."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
It's good to vape to, though.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, when's a bad time?
-Never.
Vaping is totally cool.
-Dude, vaping is totally cool.
You know what I do?
I put on, like, a space helmet.
-Right.
-Sneak a vape up in there.
Or use a coat hanger.
-Right.
-So I can just shove the vape --
-It's like a giant, like, a
fishbowl, like a giant fishbowl.
-Correct, it's hard
to even breathe.
But once I get the vape
in there --
-Then that's when life starts.
-As fast as I can go.
-I do vape animals.
-And it's the full fogged out --
There's no weed
or anything in it.
-No, no, no.
It's just cherry-flavored vape.
-It's cherry-flavored vape.
[ Laughter ]
And I just think
it's cool to see --
-It's just cool, man.
Just totally cool.
-You know what I write?
With my nose in the glass?
-What?
-"Help me."
[ Laughter ]
-It's fun.
-You know what?
Who will save your soul? Jewel.
[ Applause ]
-This one is from @torontostar.
This is from the Toronto
newspaper, "The Toronto Star."
They said, "The Toronto
Maple Leafs Blowers."
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for playing, guys.
This one's from @raflocruz99.
She says, "The Charlotte
Murder Hornets."
There you go, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And this last one's
from @The4thPsychic --
sorry, @The4thPhysic.
-Oh, physic. Not psychic.
[ Laughter ]
The 4th Psychic.
-The 4th Physic.
-Physic. Physic?
-P-H-Y-S-I-C.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, physic.
-Psychic.
-Psychic?
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to say psychic.
-I don't know
how to read anymore.
-You know what? Too much vaping.
Yeah, yeah.
-He says, "The Sacramento
Tiger Kings."
There you go, everybody.
Those are our hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.